le blé va-t-il manquer avec la guerre en
ukraine et l'arrêt des livraisons russes
le marché des céréales s'affole
des pays du monde entier pourrait se
retrouver face à un risque de pénurie
alors la france est elle capable de
produire davantage
en haute garonne jean-françois la masse
et cultive 240 hectares mais il pourrait
faire plus une partie de ses terres
n'est pas exploité
attirer lebron ici les voilà ce n'est
pas de souci
mais permettez pourquoi je la mettrais
pas moi il faut re labouré il faut
relancer bombe mais aujourd'hui dans la
conjoncture où en est on m obliger sur
me coûte au moins dérangé et terres
laissées en jachère au repos mais qui
pourrait voir grandir du blé aujourd'hui
l'europe oblige les céréaliers a laissé
en jachère 4% de leurs terres face à la
crise cette règle pourrait être supprimé
demain par la commission européenne
l'objectif produire plus pour livrer les
pays tributaires du blé russe et
ukrainien notamment au moyen-orient ou
en afrique mais selon certains experts
des jachères ne suffiront pas dans les
mois à venir ça va pas répondre à la
problématique que l'on a à court terme
ça sera si vous voulez pour la récolte
2023 c'est-à-dire dans un an et demi à
très court terme les solutions
n'existent pas si ce n'est un
rationnement de la demande qui pour le
blé est compliqué supprimer les terres
en jachère pause pour d'autres un second
problème d'ordre écologique
déstabiliser la biodiversité
ces jachères qui sont des zones refuges
sur des fermes permettent d'accueillir
des insectes ou des oiseaux qui se
nourrissent des ravageurs de cultures
des insectes ravageurs de cultures et
permettent d'aider à produire sans
utiliser de pesticides en france
trois cent cinquante mille hectares de
jachères pourrait de nouveau être
cultive
elle a terminé